this is conor mcgregor born into a
working-class family from the suburbs of
dublin at one point he was a plumber
living on social welfare in 2021 forbes
named him the highest paid athlete in
the world that year he had a net worth
of 180 million dollars conor mcgregor is
one of the most dominant fighters in ufc
history a two division champion in ufc
he was for a time considered the king of
combat sports living a lavish life and
earning a nine-figure payday with the
help of a dubious boxing match against
floyd money mayweather but while
mcgregor took naturally to the superstar
life it wasn't something he was born
into coming from a working-class family
from the suburbs of dublin he journeyed
his way through childhood gyms a stint
as a plumber's apprentice and eventual
worldwide fame as the most notorious
fighter on the planet and the biggest
name in the ufc this is the story of
mcgregor's rise to the top of the world
conor mcgregor was born on july 14 1988
he would spend his youth in kremlin a
suburb of dublin in dublin he would meet
his now longtime coach john cavanaugh
after going into one of kavanaugh's gyms
mcgregor beat up two of the best
fighters there in a sparring session
that he took a bit too seriously
kavanaugh responded by pinning him and
throwing heavy blows until conor
promised he was there for training and
not for a street brawl
uninterested in school he took to
plumbing as a trade and did what he
could to make a living for some time
there were times when he would work
12-hour days before heading to the gym
to train as a fighter it was around this
time that he started dating his longtime
girlfriend dee devlin
when he gave up plumbing to train
full-time his parents disapproved of the
decision so much so he and his father
came to blows he told his father that
he'll be a self-made millionaire by the
age of 25. mcgregor took part in his
first mma match in march 2008 for the
london-based promotion cage warriors
defeating gary morris by tko in the
second round
he would go four and two through his
first six fights before starting the
winning streak that would take him to
international fame during that run of
early fights mcgregor attended his first
ever ufc event and caught chuck
liddell's attention long enough to snag
a selfie it's the type of encounter
mcgregor would soon find himself on the
other side of often
after his 4-2 start conor would win his
next eight fights all within the first
two rounds and become a two-division
champion of cage warriors buzz continued
to grow and he was eventually booked for
his first fight with ufc
on april 6 2013 mcgregor made his ufc
debut against marcus brimage winning by
knockout in the first round just a week
before that fight he had picked up a
welfare check for 188 euros to help him
get by but mcgregor took home the prize
for knockout of the night and the 60 000
bonus that came with it later in life he
would name his boat the 188 in memory of
those checks
ufc president dana white was immediately
impressed with mcgregor he said he was
blown away by mcgregor's debut in
stockholm it was the beginning of a
profitable relationship from there
conor's run of dominance continued
he won five more fights four of which
didn't make it through two rounds he
beat chad mendez and claimed the interim
ufc featherweight championship this put
mcgregor in a position to face jose aldo
in a unification bout for the ufc
featherweight championship
in the lead-up to the fight mcgregor
said he was going to unify the belts
destroy the featherweight division and
take the lightweight division as well
on december 12 2015 mcgregor knocked out
jose aldo in just 13 seconds it was the
fastest finish ever for a ufc title
fight again it was his unstoppable left
that did the job
true to his word mcgregor set out to win
in the lightweight division and a fight
with rafael dos anos for the title was
set for ufc 196 in march but dos anjos
had to withdraw after breaking his foot
leading former lightweight contender
nate diaz to step up on short notice to
face mcgregor
diaz had been training as a welterweight
at 170 pounds and mcgregor decided he
would again gain the weight to meet him
there jumping two weight classes in just
two weeks
mcgregor was the heavy favorite going
into the fight but would get caught in
the second round and end up tapping out
after diaz locked in a rear naked choke
hold giving mcgregor the first loss of
his ufc career despite his shocking loss
to nate diaz in 2016 mcgregor became the
first mixed martial artist to appear on
forbes list of the hundred highest paid
athletes taking 22 million dollars on
the year between his fights with diaz
aldo and a variety of sponsorships after
a series of negotiations that included
mcgregor being dropped from the ufc 200
for refusing to go on a press tour
promoting the fight mcgregor ds2 was set
for ufc 202. the fight was a bloodbath
thrilling fans around the world it would
go down as one of mcgregor's most
memorable performances in the octagon in
the end both fighters would once again
receive fight of the night honours with
connor winning by majority decision
just three months later he would
challenge eddie alvarez for the ufc
lightweight championship the fight was
set for ufc 205
in the prelude to the fight mcgregor
showed his normal confidence telling his
opponent to show up so he could break
his face
conor would win by tko in the second
round and became the first ever fighter
to hold ufc titles in multiple divisions
after the win mcgregor said that he
would take time off from fighting to
wait for the birth of his child during
that time off mcgregor began pushing for
a boxing match against mayweather rumors
that negotiations were underway began
swirling a month later it was announced
that the fight was officially on
mayweather and mcgregor would meet in
the ring in las vegas for what would
surely be the biggest fight of the year
mcgregor made the announcement official
with a post on instagram trolling the
undefeated boxer the bill to the fight
on august 26 was fast and furious both
mayweather and mcgregor set out on a
four city tour to promote the fight
trading verbal jabs and obscenities
along the way
at the next confrontation in front of a
particularly frisky crowd in toronto
mcgregor called out mayweather's rumored
illiteracy much to the delight of those
who had gathered to watch the press
conference experts didn't give mcgregor
much of a chance to beat mayweather with
former champion mike tyson saying
mcgregor going gonna get killed
additionally some mocked mcgregor for
training sessions he made public
especially his bag work and his warm-up
routine
mcgregor never really stood a chance
against mayweather and was eventually
dispatched by tko in the 10th round but
despite the loss mcgregor was still
surely pleased with the result earning a
rumored 100 million dollars for his role
in the circus of a fight
after the mayweather fight mcgregor took
a bit more time off to enjoy his riches
he went to the 2018 world cup final and
did so as a personal guest of russian
president vladimir putin conor mcgregor
announced the launch of his whiskey
brand in 2017. a year later the irishman
launched the brand with the name proper
12. proper 12 irish whiskey became conor
mcgregor's first business venture
outside combat sports riding on the
sportsman's showmanship the brand
generated around 1 billion dollars in
revenue just in the first year of its
sales
but soon enough there was reason to
tease his return to the ufc his natural
opponent was khabib the undefeated
russian fighter who had taken over as
champion of the lightweight division in
mcgregor's absence things came to a head
when mcgregor bizarrely attacked a bus
khabib was on ahead of ufc 223 leading
to several injuries to other fighters
mcgregor would later explain that he was
acting to protect his teammate artem
loboff who was confronted by khabib at a
hotel mcgregor would be taken into
custody and charged with an assault for
his attack but ultimately got off
relatively unscathed and thus the stage
was set for a fight between mcgregor and
khabib for the ufc lightweight title
ufc even used footage of mcgregor's
attack on the bus to promote the
upcoming fight
at the fight khabib dominated mcgregor
eventually forcing him to tap out in the
fourth round
when the final bell rang khabib would
leap out of the octagon and start a
brawl with some of mcgregor's teammates
resulting in suspensions for both
fighters
despite the loss mcgregor was expected
to return to the octagon in 2019 having
signed a six-fight deal with the ufc
ahead of the khabib fight instead
mcgregor shockingly announced his
retirement from fighting in march 2019
but as is often the case mcgregor's
retirement didn't stick and he began
needling for a rematch with khabib but
there were other fighters in line for a
title shot though meaning mcgregor would
have to wait his turn
in the meantime mcgregor had more
trouble with the law in march of 2019
mcgregor was arrested after an encounter
with a fan in miami slapping a phone out
of his hand and stomping on it then in
april mcgregor reportedly punched an
older man in a dublin pub after he
refused a shot of the irish fighter's
whiskey eventually mcgregor started
focusing on his return to ufc long-time
ufc contender donald cowboy cerrone
emerged as a potential opponent mcgregor
made quick work of cerrone knocking the
cowboy out in just 40 seconds after
opening the fight with a devastating
shoulder charge and ending it with a
brutal series of punches
after the fight mcgregor paid respect to
his opponent and even embraced cowboy's
grandmother in the octagon a few months
after the fight mcgregor announced his
retirement once again but it wouldn't
last long
by august he was teasing another
potential superstar boxing bout this
time against manny pacquiao but by
october his next ufc bout was in the
works setting up a rematch against
dustin poirier on fight island mcgregor
previously beat poirier in 2014 winning
via first round knockout the two faced
off again at ufc 257
with poirier winning by tko in round two
the internet had a field day with
mcgregor's loss as he became a meme
dubbed sleepy mcgregor
the two then faced off again for the
much-anticipated trilogy fight at ufc
264. poirier again won by tko with
mcgregor breaking his leg at the end of
round one the post-fight interview
became one of mcgregor's most legendary
moments in ufc history
outside of fighting his whiskey business
became a success proper 12 was the
sponsor of the deontay wilder vs tyson
fury 2 fight in 2018 mcgregor and the
ufc signed a six-fight contract that
also included a proper 12 presence as a
sponsor for every card the irishman
fights on in 2020 proper 12 became the
fourth most popular irish whiskey brand
globally in terms of sales proximo
spirits acquired the majority stake of
proper 12 in a 600 million deal it is
unclear how much conor mcgregor made
directly through the deal but it's going
to be quite substantial he still hasn't
retired from fighting yet after poirier
there's plenty of other opponents
mcgregor might take on
he's repeatedly expressed a desire for
another shot at now retired champion
khabib
mcgregor has also been tied to a
potential return to boxing where a fight
against manny pacquiao could potentially
net 250 million dollars there's no
telling what the future holds for
mcgregor
in every journey to success there's a
lesson to be learned so what can we
learn from mcgregor's rise to the top
his genius lies in his ability to
leverage media attention there's no
doubt he's an incredible fighter and has
helped the ufc become much more
mainstream critics will often point out
that he's too controversial overdramatic
and trash talks too much
however that's the exact reason why he's
become so successful
we live in an attention economy he is a
master at getting attention and
generating media hype in the fight game
people don't want to see two fighters
get on stage shaking hands they want the
drama the hype and the trash talking
it's the buzz around the fight that
makes it exciting and if that hype
brings in viewers and media attention no
matter if mcgregor wins or loses he
still gets a massive payday with all
that attention he's become his own brand
ultimately making him incredibly rich
and successful
thanks for staying till the end of this
video if you enjoyed this video then be
sure to hit the like button drop a
comment subscribe and hit the
notification bell for more content like
this
also be sure to check out our other
videos on this channel links are in the
description and we'll see you in the
next one